RAF Lucas Scotland home of Warner
world's fastest planes
tomatoe f3
the pilots and navigators here are all
on QR a quick reaction alert when the
alarm sounds they have just minutes to
scramble to defend British airspace
these guys work at top speed but when it
comes to the kitchen they haven't got a
clue how to be quick morning
main problem of the time during the day
we actually get about maybe half an hour
for lunch to cook healthy food quickly
at all that's why at the moment in the
short gap between flying rooting pretty
rubbish food the the state were in to be
honest we were reduced to cheese
toasties it's pretty an adventurous
worry for a bunch of men that fly very
expensive nice toys these guys say they
have no time to cook but I'm here to
prove no matter how little time you have
anyone could cook good food fast what an
absolute beauty tornado it is f3 f3 look
at it my gosh what was finest air
defence fighter the best of the best
best of the best in cooking terms it's
three Michelin star twelve to speed of
times just over five thousand miles now
yeah a thousand miles an hour just about
that yeah yeah you fancy trying to go
for ride world would love to get a get
thing
lucky chef for them I'm not even in
there yet already with my the pilots can
experience up to seven times the force
of gravity in the f3 so it's vital I
wear the right kit
beautiful
that's amazing possibly
840 miles an hour that's 14 miles a
minute
my
my
a lifetime thank you very much oh you
lady vols good fun lot of guns
I tell you what's four kings i canti a
[ __ ] thing yeah I've lost my appetite
I'm starving your staff I am starving
and you say you're gonna cook for me so
they've shown me their skill in the air
now it's time to get them up to speed in
the kitchen still feel a little bit I'm
absolutely amazing I'm gobsmacked on the
back of what I've experienced and you
know a [ __ ] thrill of a lifetime
without a shadow down you can't survive
on a toastie so with only 25 minutes
until their next flight and the teacher
had to cook something that doesn't come
between two slices of bread okay
gentlemen I feel the need for speed now
yeah something very simple
straightforward I'm bloody good for you
yeah a really nice pan-roasted cot with
chorizo and a fragrant rice peeler
father is in file for Sri so it gives a
really nice flavor to the cop not gonna
show you video gets rid of this time to
get a move on okay so news in there
that's for the right cardamon Barney
a couple of clothes sitting will stick
smell about now is amazing and put a
clock with are they cooking the cod on
the skin okay I eat packed with protein
and it keeps it nice and intact you lay
there way just to stop there's a bit of
a different sort of take on a toasting
for the guys yeah what do you think can
you put that in a toasty no check on
that rice and we're ready to serve up
guys yep now for me the most important
thing there of course was the speed that
well there's 12 minutes open its happy
this is good food but fast food yeah it
is yeah that was a [ __ ] pleasure
appetite back yeah thank you
they're extraordinary yeah stay off the
toasters yeah yeah and I'll stay at your
cockpit
but that should be the fish okay how big
do you want nobs bay